c'est le genre de scène qui sont devenus
de plus en plus fréquente des policiers
qui défoncent la porte avec un marteau
cette fois dans les studios de la
principale associés d'alexis navalni
lioubov soldats tombent mais quand vous
travaillez sur d'autres chléo l'entend
crier qui est dit
et qu'est ce que vous voulez une heure
plus tôt c'était la femme d'alex et
navales néolia que les services de
sécurité frapper al akwaa
la fenêtre de son immeuble elle hurle
qu'il fouille l'appartement et qu'on lui
refuse d'après son avocat où est cette
descente comme celles ci ont été menés
dans sept endroits différents
elles sont toutes liées à navalni dont
l'équipe est constamment harcelé et
intimidé les autorités semblent
d'ailleurs prête à tout pour taire la
dissidence dans la ville de hama en
kiosque dans le nord de la russie
une femme qui a dirigé ces bonhommes de
neige qui tiennent des pancartes anti
poutine a été détenu et interrogé tout
alors qu'une autre journée de
manifestations s'organisent pour
dimanche
heureusement car même en prison alexis
navalni a réussi avec son vaste réseau a
réveillé un mouvement de protestation
comme on en voit rarement en russie de
moscou à vladivostok
des dizaines de milliers de reus ont
manifesté samedi et pas seulement pour
demander sa libération
de plus en plus disent le faire parce
qu'ils ont vu cette vidéo où tu
m'apportes belgique ont un palais
majestueux qui aurait été construit pour
poutine en bordure de la mer noire avec
des pauvres une enquête de deux heures
signées navalni qui a été vue plus de 5
millions de fois sur youtube
même minecraft on a fait le décor de son
jeu vidéo
le président proxim qu'on avait pas vu
depuis longtemps en public pour dire que
le château n'est pas le sien la colère
serait pas mis en visioconférence avec
le forum économique de davos auquel il
participait pour la première fois en dix
ans l'avenir poutine a mis en garde la
planète des risques d'un nouveau conflit
mondial si les différentes sont pas
réglés s'y reproduire mes pains
moussants navalni alors que le g7
condamne fermement la russie et la
répression violente contre ceux qui se
battent pour lui